We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. You are listening to 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars. You are listening. You are listening. You are listening.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州乃至全球范围内开展合作与创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学为提升所有生物生活质量这一使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。您正在收听的是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。您正在收听。您正在收听。您正在收听。
My name is Eric Eberhart, and I'm the creator of the site. You are listening to Chicago, you are listening to New York, you are listening to Montreal, and you are listening to San Francisco. I'm at the 1125 Rally North, graduating North at 880, so I take up trucks with the tailgate down. There's a friendly dog in the back of the vehicle that has no lead or color of the phrase, the dog will fall out. Last year after the Giants One the World Series, I was out in the streets of San Francisco, checking out all the different celebrations going on. And when I got home, I was looking on Twitter and I saw a lot of people were posting links to what's happening in their neighborhood, people out lighting bonfires. and one thing that kept coming up was,
我叫埃里克·埃伯哈特，我是这个网站的创建者。您正在收听芝加哥，您正在收听纽约，您正在收听蒙特利尔，您正在收听旧金山。我在 1125 Rally North，在 880 公路向北行驶，所以我开着皮卡车，后挡板是放下的。车后有一只友好的狗，没有牵引绳或项圈，按照这个说法，狗会掉下去。去年巨人队赢得世界大赛后，我走在旧金山的街头，查看各种正在进行的庆祝活动。当我回到家时，我在推特上看到很多人发布了他们社区正在发生的事情的链接，人们在外面点燃篝火。有一件事不断出现，
Hey, check out the San Francisco police radio on Soma FM. So I started listening to it. It was cool and got bored after a couple minutes and started putting on some of my music in the background. And something about that, there was like a synergy between the police scanner and like the music I was playing That really sounded cool and I wanted to find a way to share that with people. So that's where I came up with the idea for this site. And since it came online on March 6, 2011, I've spent what might be considered
嘿，去看看 Soma FM 上的旧金山警察电台。所以我开始听它。它很酷，但几分钟后我就觉得无聊了，开始在后台播放我的一些音乐。关于这一点，警察扫描仪和我播放的音乐之间产生了一种协同效应，听起来真的很酷，我想找到一种方法与人们分享。这就是我产生这个网站想法的地方。自 2011 年 3 月 6 日上线以来，我花了很多时间，可能被认为是
an inordinate amount of time listening to, you are listening to. Some people think it's peaceful, some people think it's creepy, I think it's mesmerizing, and it's creepy. I think it's mesmerizing. And it's elegant, isn't it? Simplicity. So when you load the page, there's a little JavaScript file that pulls in an audio stream
花费了过多的时间在听，您正在收听。有些人认为它很平静，有些人认为它很诡异，我觉得它很迷人，而且很诡异。我觉得它很迷人。而且它很优雅，不是吗？简洁。所以当你加载页面时，有一个小的 JavaScript 文件会拉取一个音频流
from radioreference.com, they provide the police radio audio. A playlist from SoundCloud, which is a music sharing site, which has been screened by Everhart so that the playlist only has these dreamy ambient soundscapes that complement the police scanner audio. And it also loads the background image, which is coming from Flickr. Those are the three main parts and they're all coming from sites other than my own. And it's all legal and free and only possible because each of the companies provide simple web APIs.
来自 radioreference.com，他们提供警察电台音频。还有一个来自 SoundCloud（一个音乐共享网站）的播放列表，该列表经过埃伯哈特的筛选，因此播放列表只包含那些与警察扫描仪音频相辅相成的梦幻环境音景。它还会加载来自 Flickr 的背景图像。这是三个主要部分，它们都来自我自己的网站之外。这一切都是合法且免费的，只有因为每家公司都提供了简单的网络 API 才有可能实现。
Application programming interface that specifically promote this kind of sharing and mashing up. You can create something new that might not be what the creator intended. The design choice being made by these sites, the thing that you are listening to is exploiting, is a relinquishing of a little bit of the control of their data in order for that data to spread across the web in ways that they never could have imagined. In this way, outside and independent developers like Everhart can act as a kind of R&D department.
应用程序编程接口专门促进这种共享和混搭。你可以创造出一些可能并非创作者初衷的新事物。这些网站所做的设计选择，即你正在收听的内容所利用的，是对其数据控制权的一点点放弃，以便这些数据能以他们从未想象过的方式在网络上传播。通过这种方式，像埃伯哈特这样的外部和独立开发者可以充当一种研发部门。
Radio reference and flicker and SoundCloud and the artists offering creative commons, wealthy free music on SoundCloud did not imagine this use of their content. But they do have an API. They just created a shareable architecture that taps into a remixing culture where new ideas can flourish.
Radio Reference、Flickr、SoundCloud 以及在 SoundCloud 上提供知识共享、免版税音乐的艺术家们并没有预见到他们的内容会被这样使用。但他们确实有 API。他们只是创建了一个可共享的架构，利用了一种新思想可以蓬勃发展的混音文化。
Since the site is launched and it where gets around, it's been very popular. I've been contacted by lots and lots of artists from SoundCloud and they all want to be part of it. They all think it's cool and they're asking me can I have my music included on your site? Now they're not getting anything out of it. They're not getting paid. There's no royalties. There's nothing like that. But they are getting exposure. I think it, they're not getting paid, there's no royalties, there's nothing like that. But they are getting exposure, I think these are people who posted their music up there because they wanted to share it with people, and now they're finding they're sharing with a lot more people.
自从网站推出并传播开来后，它非常受欢迎。我收到了很多很多来自 SoundCloud 的艺术家的联系，他们都想参与其中。他们都觉得这很酷，并问我能否把他们的音乐包含在你的网站上？现在他们从中得不到任何东西。他们没有得到报酬。没有版税。没有类似的东西。但他们获得了曝光度。我认为，他们没有得到报酬，没有版税，没有类似的东西。但他们获得了曝光度，我认为这些人把他们的音乐发布在那里是因为他们想与人们分享，现在他们发现他们正在与更多的人分享。
So it's kind of like a virtuous cycle, I guess, where I created something, I'm not looking for anything in return, the artists are getting something out of it, soundcloud and radio reference are getting something out of it because there are more people are becoming aware of their services. So really at zero cost to me or to the artists, we're all building something together that kind of enhances everyone's work. Designing for openness allows others to answer the questions that you don't have the answers to, but it's greatest power maybe that it allows others to answer the questions that you don't have the answers to. But it's great as power may be that it allows others to ask the questions that you haven't even thought to ask.
所以这就像一个良性循环，我想，我创造了一些东西，我不求任何回报，艺术家们从中得到了东西，SoundCloud 和 Radio Reference 也从中得到了东西，因为有更多的人开始了解他们的服务。所以实际上对我或艺术家们来说是零成本，我们都在共同构建一些东西，这在某种程度上增强了每个人的工作。为开放而设计允许他人回答你没有答案的问题，但它最大的力量可能在于它允许他人回答你没有答案的问题。但它最大的力量可能在于它允许他人提出你甚至没想过要问的问题。
No, I don't have no five, I'm now 11th. Thank you. Say welcome. 99% invisible was produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. To find out more, and subscribe to the podcast, go to 99%indisible.org.
不，我没有五，我现在是第 11 个。谢谢。说欢迎。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马尔斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持，用创造力创造不同。这是 KALW、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。欲了解更多信息并订阅播客，请访问 99%invisible.org。
Hey guys, it's Roman Mars again and we're done with the radio portion of 99% of visible we're on to the podcast bonus content of the show that people seem to be pretty happy about so I'm going to try to keep doing this if I can. I had another question for Eric Everhart about future plans. And he brought up an old radio piece that I did. And so we're gonna listen to his answer about these sort of evolution and things he wants to do with you are listening to. Then he's gonna mention something very special to me
嘿大家，我是罗曼·马尔斯，我们已经完成了《99%隐形》的广播部分，现在进入人们似乎非常喜欢的播客奖励内容，所以我如果可以的话会尽量继续这样做。我还有另一个关于未来计划的问题要问埃里克·埃伯哈特。他提到了我做过的一段旧广播片段。所以我们要听听他关于这种演变以及他想用“您正在收听”做的事情的回答。然后他会提到对我来说非常特别的事情
here at the end of this clip. So here you go. Moving forward, I'd like to find a way for people to be able to contribute to the site. Some experimenting with more APIs, more services online that allow people to share audio, post their thoughts and their writings about stuff. And then I want to find a way to be able to integrate those into the site, into the audio stream so that ultimately, maybe you can choose between police radio or maybe like the audio
在这个片段的结尾。所以给你。展望未来，我想找到一种方法让人们能够为网站做出贡献。正在尝试更多的 API，更多的在线服务，允许人们分享音频，发布他们对事物的想法和文章。然后我想找到一种方法能够将这些整合到网站中，整合到音频流中，这样最终，也许你可以在警察电台或类似音频之间进行选择
equivalent of Twitter. What did you have for breakfast? What was the last thing that you watched on television before you went to bed? Because I think just all those things mashed together would create an even more interesting kind of mashup of experiences and sounds and textures. I was looking at your website,
推特的等价物。你早餐吃了什么？你睡觉前看的最后一部电视节目是什么？因为我认为所有这些东西混在一起会创造出一种更有趣的体验、声音和质感的混搭。我当时正在看你的网站，
and one of the things was the Sting RadioNet, which that kind of, I'm like, oh look, someone's already done this with different technology 20 years ago, but that kind of I'm like, oh look, someone's already done this with different technology 20 years ago But that's that kind of was right where I was aiming which was like be able to take people's little short snippets of speech and just throw it in there and see what happens So that thing you mentioned radio net, which is by Max new house I was obsessed with especially in about 2005 I was working for the
其中一件事是 Sting RadioNet，那种，我当时想，哦看，有人 20 年前就用不同的技术做过这个了，但那种，我当时想，哦看，有人 20 年前就用不同的技术做过这个了，但那种正是我的目标，即能够获取人们简短的语音片段，然后直接扔进去看看会发生什么。所以你提到的那个 RadioNet，是由马克斯·纽豪斯制作的，我特别着迷，大约在 2005 年，我当时在为
Third Coast International Audio Festival. I had a Track Max new house down and interviewed him about his various public engagement art projects on public radio that he did decades before. And so here's the piece I did for the program resound. And so the voice that you're going to hear is the host of resound Gwen Maxi. And then you're going to hear me talking. And you know, it's about what was that six years ago. So it's a little looser. It's a little, you know, it's not a perfect radio story, but you know, I was still learning. So anyway, I hope you enjoy it. And I'll join you at the other side of this piece. Basically, radio is a one-way medium.
第三海岸国际音频节工作。我追踪到了马克斯·纽豪斯，并采访了他关于他在几十年前在公共广播上所做的各种公共参与艺术项目。所以这是我为节目《回声》制作的片段。所以你将听到的声音是《回声》的主持人格温·马克西。然后你会听到我说话。你知道，那是六年前的事了。所以它有点松散，有点，你知道，它不是一个完美的广播故事，但你知道，我还在学习。所以无论如何，希望你喜欢。我会在这个片段的另一端加入你们。基本上，广播是一种单向媒介。
We talk, you listen. Sure, there are public radio calling shows that are meant to sound live, but more often than not, they're highly edited and pre-produced. Listeners hate to hear that, but it's true. But there have been brief moments in the history of the medium where the airwaves really were a free for all and completely new forms of sound were born.
我们说，你听。当然，有一些公共广播的呼叫节目听起来像是直播，但更多时候，它们是经过高度编辑和预先制作的。听众讨厌听到这个，但这是事实。但在该媒介的历史上，曾有过短暂的时刻，电波确实是自由的，全新的声音形式诞生了。
Max Newhouse makes sound works that are neither music nor events. He coined the term sound installation and has been the engine behind all sorts of new ways of thinking about and experiencing sound. Our producer Roman Mars tracked Newhouse down in Italy. Now Roman is responsible for the sound of resound, all the music, voices, odd sounds, and effects that you hear in between pieces, and that, I can tell you, is no small task. But when you actually hear Roman on the air talking, you know it's because he's become obsessed with something.
马克斯·纽豪斯制作的声音作品既不是音乐也不是事件。他创造了“声音装置”这个词，并且一直是各种关于思考和体验声音的新方式背后的引擎。我们的制作人罗曼·马尔斯在意大利追踪到了纽豪斯。现在罗曼负责《回声》的声音，你在片段之间听到的所有音乐、声音、奇怪的声音和效果，我可以告诉你，这绝非易事。但当你真正听到罗曼在广播中说话时，你知道那是因为他已经对某件事着迷了。
For the show I create these mixes, we sound clashes comprised of layered elements that relate to the themes of the program. And one of the elements in this mix, the one that you're hearing right now, is actually when I use a lot on lots of different shows. But to be able to hear it, we're gonna have to turn down some of this other stuff. So let's take down the transmissions from Saturn. I don't know if you recognize those,
为了这个节目，我制作了这些混音，我们用与节目主题相关的分层元素组成的混音。这个混音中的一个元素，也就是你现在听到的这个，实际上是我在很多不同的节目中经常使用的。但为了能听到它，我们得调低其他一些东西。所以让我们调低来自土星的传输。我不知道你是否认出那些，
those are transmissions from Saturn. And the Yankee Hotel Fox Travelman. And the music. That's the band Miwa, they roll. This, right there. That's Radio Net and for two hours this played on 200 National Public Radio affiliate stations in 1977 on a beautiful Sunday afternoon. It's a composition with 10,000 contributing musicians. It's a sound entity, really. But I'm going to head on myself.
那些是来自土星的传输。还有《洋基旅馆狐步舞曲》。还有音乐。那是乐队 Miwa，他们滚动。这个，就在那里。那是 RadioNet，在 1977 年的一个美丽的周日下午，这在 200 个国家公共广播电台附属电台播放了两个小时。这是一个由 10,000 名贡献音乐家组成的作曲。它实际上是一个声音实体。但我有点超前了。
RadioNet is part of a continuum of broadcast works by Max Newhouse, starting with a public supply one in 1966. I'm Max Newhouse. I work with sound as an artist. with a public supply one in 1966. I'm Max Newhouse. I work with sound as an artist and as an inventor sometimes even, I have done so for most of my adult life. So the last, let's see, almost 50 years. I was asked to do an interview, a radio interview, on WBAI in New York. And I thought rather than doing an interview, what I would try to do a work that would be for the radio.
RadioNet 是马克斯·纽豪斯广播作品连续体的一部分，始于 1966 年的《公共供应一号》。我是马克斯·纽豪斯。我作为一名艺术家，有时甚至作为一名发明家，与声音打交道，我成年后的大部分时间都是这样做的。所以最后，让我们看看，差不多 50 年了。我被要求在纽约的 WBAI 电台做一个采访，一个广播采访。我想与其做一个采访，不如尝试做一个为广播而创作的作品。
This was in 1966. At that time there were no radio calling shows, so the idea of connecting the telephone network to the radio station which I wanted to do to make it two-way space out of the radio rather out of a radio broadcast rather than just a one-way one. Well, it's unheard of and it was difficult to do. In fact, the engineer was so sure that we would have so many bad words broadcast that he refused to consider the project except as an interview.
那是在 1966 年。当时还没有广播呼叫节目，所以将电话网络连接到广播电台的想法，我想做的是让广播变成一个双向空间，而不是仅仅是一个单向的广播。嗯，这闻所未闻，而且很难做到。事实上，工程师非常确定我们会广播很多脏话，以至于他拒绝考虑这个项目，除非作为一次采访。
So he said in the end he would put the microphone in the studio for two hours and what I put into the microphone was up to me. So I got ten telephone lines installed into this WBAI studio and built a kind of root goldberg automatic answering system because they're in 1966 the Renault answering machine, Z-Think, which allowed me to from a homemade box, I'll make mixer control, pick up the phone and mix sounds which I put into an amplifier and put a loudspeaker
所以他最后说他会把麦克风放在演播室里两个小时，我放进麦克风的内容由我决定。所以我安装了十条电话线到这个 WBAI 演播室，并建立了一种鲁布·戈德堡式的自动应答系统，因为在 1966 年，雷诺答录机，Z-Think，允许我从一个自制的盒子里，我做一个混音器控制，拿起电话并混合声音，我把声音放入一个放大器并放一个扬声器
in front of his microphone and when it came to funny kind of party, that everybody wasn't seeing each other, everybody was listening to each other. And the way I describe it now is kind of a life, it was a wild, live sound collage, but people also hearing their own voices on the radio was, you know, a startling thing at that time. Not many people had paper quarters, so hearing your own voice was a revelation, you know. So it's quite exciting. Yes, I mean, it was raw and wild. In fact, it wasn't any swearing and WBA kept its lights. and WBA accepted slides. And... ...
在他麦克风的前面，当它变成一种有趣的聚会时，每个人都没有看到对方，每个人都在听对方。我现在描述它的方式是一种生活，它是一个狂野的、现场的声音拼贴，但人们在广播中听到自己的声音，你知道，在当时是一件令人吃惊的事情。没有多少人有录音机，所以听到自己的声音是一种启示，你知道。所以这很令人兴奋。是的，我的意思是，它是原始而狂野的。事实上，没有任何脏话，WBAI 保留了它的执照。WBAI 接受了幻灯片。而且…………
... ... Here were a couple iterations of Max Newhouse's public supply, including a Peabody award-winning broadcast on WFMT in Chicago, where collars' voices activated special instruments, in addition to coming through clearly, so that what they were saying could actually be understood. And what do people say when they're given the opportunity addition to coming through clearly so that what they were saying could actually be understood.
……这里有几个马克斯·纽豪斯《公共供应》的迭代版本，包括在芝加哥 WFMT 电台获得皮博迪奖的广播，其中呼叫者的声音激活了特殊的乐器，除了清晰地传出之外，这样他们所说的话实际上可以被理解。当人们有机会时，他们会说什么？除了清晰地传出之外，这样他们所说的话实际上可以被理解。
And what do people say when they're given the opportunity to be on the air for the very first time? The answer is kind of the same high mom hand waving goofy sorts of things that they do when they're given the opportunity today. Banana man, banana man, are I like my banana. A few years later, a fairly new and compared to today, much more experimental NPR came calling and offered Max the opportunity to do the exact same thing, but on a nationwide scale, which brings us back to RadioNet. National Public Radio presents RadioNet, a live nationwide composition by Max Newhouse.
当人们第一次有机会在广播中发言时，他们会说什么？答案和今天他们有机会时所做的那些“嗨妈妈”、挥手、傻乎乎的事情差不多。香蕉人，香蕉人，我喜欢我的香蕉。几年后，一个相当新且与今天相比实验性强得多的 NPR 电台打来电话，并提供给马克斯机会做完全相同的事情，但在全国范围内，这把我们带回了 RadioNet。国家公共广播电台呈现 RadioNet，由马克斯·纽豪斯创作的全国性现场作曲。
Radio Net is a piece of music. In this case, we'll be using the National Public Radio network to actually generate a piece of music from sounds, sound material, phoned in by anyone from anywhere. phoned in by anyone from anywhere. I think the most important thing for the listener to realize is that we're making a piece of music. And all one really has to do is listen with an open mind. NPR now invites you to become part of Radio Net. Dial any one of the following telephone numbers.
Radio Net 是一首音乐作品。在这种情况下，我们将使用国家公共广播电台网络，通过任何人从任何地方打进来的声音、声音材料来实际生成一首音乐。任何人从任何地方打进来。我认为听众最需要意识到的是我们正在创作一首音乐。而一个人真正需要做的就是以开放的心态去倾听。NPR 现在邀请您成为 Radio Net 的一部分。拨打以下任何一个电话号码。
At that point, I was really fighting, you know, this idea that music could be made another way of this idea of really activating a lay public and inventing their own music. It was just, you know, it was from Mars. RadioNet sounds different from public supply for a number of reasons. New house took advantage of the NPR distribution system of the time called a round robin which connected all the 200 stations. And how this was normally used was that a station would feed a program to all the others by breaking into this round robin telephone line and sending it around the loop. So New House picked five cities, New York, Dallas, Atlanta, Minneapolis, and Los Angeles, and subdivided the network into five loops each point having its own automatic mixer, which selected fractions of the sound that
在那一点上，我真的在抗争，你知道，这种音乐可以用另一种方式制作的想法，这种真正激活大众并让他们发明自己的音乐的想法。这只是，你知道，它来自火星。RadioNet 听起来与《公共供应》不同，原因有很多。纽豪斯利用了当时被称为“循环”的 NPR 分发系统，该系统连接了所有 200 个电台。这种系统通常的使用方式是，一个电台通过切入这条循环电话线并将其绕着回路发送，从而向所有其他电台提供节目。所以纽豪斯选择了五个城市：纽约、达拉斯、亚特兰大、明尼阿波利斯和洛杉矶，并将网络细分为五个回路，每个点都有自己的自动混音器，它选择了部分声音，这些声音
were being fed in by the phone callers. So during the broadcast, the sound's phoned into each city, passed through itself mixer, and started looping. With each cross-country pass each sound made another layer overlapping itself at different pitches until it gradually died away. It was the activation of an entire continent into a sound transformation box that was literally 1500 miles wide by 3,000 miles long with five inz and outs emerging in Washington DC or Max Newhouse sad and mixed them all together controlling this five-headed animal so that it didn't spin off into a massive feedback loop
是由电话呼叫者输入的。所以在广播期间，打进每个城市的声音通过它自己的混音器，并开始循环。随着每一次跨国传递，每一种声音都以不同的音高重叠自身，形成另一层，直到它逐渐消失。这是将整个大陆激活成一个声音转换盒，它实际上有 1500 英里宽，3000 英里长，五个输入和输出汇聚在华盛顿特区，马克斯·纽豪斯坐在那里，将它们全部混合在一起，控制着这只五头动物，这样它就不会陷入大规模的反馈回路。
It was a fantastic moment. I mean to go from one station with with 20 mile radius to Transcontinental in 11 years. It was quite amazing, yes. So Max, what was NPR's take on this? Because it was live, so they'd never heard it before. I mean, I imagine their collective jaws were just on the floor. It was risky and they were really in shock after it was over.
这是一个美妙的时刻。我的意思是，在 11 年内从一个半径 20 英里的电台发展到跨大陆广播。这真是太神奇了，是的。那么马克斯，NPR 对此有何看法？因为它是现场直播，所以他们以前从未听过。我的意思是，我想象他们集体的下巴都掉在地上了。这很冒险，他们在结束后真的处于震惊状态。
They didn't want to do it again. They were really terrified. Mostly, in the beginning, they were, it's all these pieces terrorized, but because they're afraid there's going to be one minute of dead air. I mean, like this. How horrible. Thirty seconds, there it. There it panicked. I mean, this. How horrible. Thirty seconds there.
他们不想再做一次。他们真的被吓坏了。主要是，一开始，他们是，所有这些片段都让他们感到恐惧，但因为他们害怕会出现一分钟的死寂。我的意思是，像这样。多可怕。三十秒，那里。它恐慌了。我的意思是，像这样。多可怕。三十秒，那里。
They're in panic. I mean, Renjoin is really quite beautiful in it. It's not hard to listen to it. But still two hours for them, of prime time, Sunday afternoon, on New Year's, the Sunday after New Year's, I think really put them in shock. But in a way, I think really put them in shock, but in a way I, you know,
他们陷入了恐慌。我的意思是，Renjoin 在其中真的很美。听起来并不难。但对他们来说，在新年后的周日下午的黄金时段播放两个小时，我想真的让他们感到震惊。但在某种程度上，我想真的让他们感到震惊，但在某种程度上我，你知道，
I had them and they had me. They couldn't, and we were there for two hours, but there was no, there was no, nobody talking about a repeat performance in 1978. It was like, God, we lived through it, we're going to have to cover our asses somehow, but they were in shock and PR was in shock. Well, RadioNet was definitely a moment in time along the public's apply. But do you think there are bigger lessons for radio in these works? Certainly radio did take this idea and it shaped it to fit its, oh, the idea of a colon show now, even though it's on the other end of the spectrum, at least it's two-way and it's fairly instantaneous.
我拥有他们，他们也拥有我。他们不能，我们在那里待了两个小时，但没有人，没有人谈论 1978 年的重播。这就像，天哪，我们活下来了，我们得想办法掩盖我们的屁股，但他们处于震惊中，NPR 处于震惊中。好吧，RadioNet 绝对是《公共供应》之后的一个时刻。但你认为这些作品对广播有什么更大的教训吗？当然，广播确实采纳了这个想法，并塑造它以适应它的，哦，现在呼叫节目的想法，即使它在光谱的另一端，至少它是双向的，而且相当即时。
You know, if you put out a call for colors to call in, you get immediately what certain people who are willing to call in are thinking about, even though it's very controlled and moderated. And that, I think think is very positive. The irony to all this work is that at the time, Max Newhouse forbade these compositions from being recorded. And his idea was that they existed as entities that any listener should be able to modify what they're
你知道，如果你发出呼吁让呼叫者打进来，你会立即得到某些愿意打进来的特定人群在想什么，即使它是非常受控和温和的。我认为这非常积极。所有这些作品的讽刺之处在于，当时马克斯·纽豪斯禁止录制这些作品。他的想法是，它们作为实体存在，任何听众都应该能够通过为作曲做出贡献来修改他们正在
hearing by contributing to the composition, something that couldn't happen if it was a music recording. He was very strict about this. No recording was to be made. And as best I can tell, not one engineer at WBAI, or WFMT, or National Public Radio, listened to him, which is the only reason why they're available to be heard today. Because you can violate a lot of rules, you can turn a one-way medium-like radio into a two-way communication device and synthesizer.
听到的内容，如果它是音乐录音，这就不可能发生。他对此非常严格。不得进行任何录音。据我所知，WBAI、WFMT 或国家公共广播电台没有一个工程师听他的话，这就是为什么它们今天还能被听到的唯一原因。因为你可以违反很多规则，你可以把像广播这样的单向媒介变成双向通信设备和合成器。
You can put people's voices on the air unmoderated and unfiltered, but under no circumstances can you stop a radio engineer from recording a sound. Our producer, Roman Mars, talking with sound artist Max Newhouse. The next evolution in Max Newhouse's broadcast work is called Oracle. That's AU RACLE. And it's sort of an online version of RadioNet, but it's 24 hours a day and anyone can play.
你可以让人们的声音在未经审查和过滤的情况下在广播中播出，但在任何情况下，你都无法阻止广播工程师录制声音。我们的制作人罗曼·马尔斯与声音艺术家马克斯·纽豪斯交谈。马克斯·纽豪斯广播作品的下一次演变被称为 Oracle。那是 AU RACLE。它有点像 RadioNet 的在线版本，但它是 24 小时全天候的，任何人都可以参与。
You can find a link on the resound page at thirdcoastfestival.org. So that's the story of RadioNet and Max Newhouse and Max died a couple years ago. I think he's just the greatest and so I'm really sad that he's gone. I'll have a link to Max Newhouse and Max died a couple of years ago. I think he's just the greatest. And so I'm really sad that he's gone. I'll have a link to Max Newhouse's website as well as the third coast international audio festival that I worked for for just over three years. And they're great.
你可以在 thirdcoastfestival.org 的《回声》页面上找到链接。这就是 RadioNet 和马克斯·纽豪斯的故事，马克斯几年前去世了。我认为他是最伟大的，所以我真的很伤心他走了。我会有一个链接到马克斯·纽豪斯几年前去世了。我认为他是最伟大的。所以我真的很伤心他走了。我会有一个链接到马克斯·纽豪斯的网站，以及我工作了三年多的第三海岸国际音频节。他们很棒。
And they have a program called ReSound that I helped work on for a long time. Their website is amazing and they're just a great group and if you want to stay on top of all the really amazing things in radio you should go to ThurkoseFestival.org. Alright, that's the story for this week. I'll talk to you next week. We hope lots of cool stuff. I guarantee it. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们有一个我参与工作了很长时间的节目叫《回声》。他们的网站很棒，他们是一个很棒的团队，如果你想掌握广播中所有真正令人惊奇的事情，你应该去 ThurkoseFestival.org。好了，这就是本周的故事。下周再聊。我们希望有很多很酷的东西。我保证。保重。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。